- Oh this better not be that good Morgan.
- Oh I know there are many secrets.
- Man, why do I gotta go first?
- Don't start crying now okay?
(xylophone music)
- [Morgan] So dad.
- So Morgan
- Ever since Delilah was about a year old,
and we got her, her first haircut
I've kept all of the hair
and I have had it made into a small
hair doll to remember her youth by.
- Oh.
That's really great.
- And I needed to get that off my chest.
- Do you put like, pins in it?
This is like very voodoo-esque.
- It's not a voodoo
doll, it's a hair doll.
It's not her essence.
- What is a hair doll?
- Some mom's make breast
milk jewelry, but I didn't
save my breast milk so I
wasn't able to do that.
- This is more than I can deal with.
How come you never showed this to me?
- Cause it's kind of embarrassing.
- I think that's fine, you know,
I understand the maternal instinct.
I live with one.
For a long freaking
time, I lived with one.
(laughter)
I love you.
- My dad used to race cars
and I definitely caught the gene
from you because I used
to race the Integra,
- Mmmmm
- Down Monterey Pass Road,
(laughter)
- And you didn't get caught.
- And I didn't get caught.
- Well, I just would want to know what
was the fastest speed you ran it?
(laughter)
To know if you ever
went faster than I did.
- I only went up to 100.
- Mmmmm
(laughter)
- Does that make you happy?
- I'm not disappointed
or anything like that.
It's pretty cool.
- I'm gonna be living with
a tribe.
That's on the Amazon River.
We're gonna take a canoe and then
we have to, I think we
have to walk 10 miles.
- Are you prepared for that?
- It can be a little bit dangerous
and they're gonna be naked
so I'm gonna have to
just be there with them.
- Naked too?
- Probably, I mean that's
what they told me that I have
to kind of fit in to the thing.
I probably won't have any phones.
I'm not gonna be able to
talk to you, probably,
but it's for eight months,
but it's a really great opportunity.
- That's a long, long time.
I'm gonna worry about you.
Fantastic, momma!
It's gonna be a really
hard experience for her,
I think you need that.
- The secret to the secret
is that it's not real.
- Oh.
It's not real.
(laughter)
Awe, I was all proud
of you, zipping down at
100 miles an hour down Monterey Pass Road.
- Well if I could travel back
in time, I would do it now.
- So I'm not actually
going to the Amazon River.
And I, made the whole thing up
and that wasn't really my secret.
And then I don't really
have a secret to tell you.
- That's bullshit?
(laughter)
- Yeah.
- You lied to me!?
I told you, Doctor Jekyll and
Mr. Hyde, she's very good.
Now I know your range as an actor.
- There is one more thing.
That is a lie I totally
don't (beep) do that!
I would never do that.
(laughter)
- I feel much better about this.
Oh my god.
- I do feel so supported, dad.
(laughter)
- I was just as nervous
lying to you as I was
if I really did have to
tell that big of a secret.
- The truth is out there!
- Were you more worried
about me having to be naked
than the Zika virus?
- Yeah.
I mean hello, my daughter naked in front
of everybody, hello, what
is this a porn or what?